Salut ! Aujourd'hui c'est un Master Class' un p'tit peu particulier
Parce que je ne vais pas vous donner un ensemble de techniques
mais 1 seule.
Ce Master Class va vous permettre
de connaître 50% des mots de n'importe quelle conversation
dans n'importe quelle langue.
Apprendre 50% d'une langue on en rêverait tous
mais est-ce bien nécessaire ?
Est-ce que c'est ça qui est vraiment utile ?
Ce qui l'est vraiment en revanche c'est de pouvoir tenir une conversation.
Et c'est là que j'interviens, c'est là que ce Master Class trouve son intérêt
puisque que depuis longtemps on a déterminé que 50% d'une conversation
se faisait avec les 100 mêmes mots.
50% de n'importe quelle conversation dans n'importe quelle langue
se fait avec une centaine de mots uniquement.
ça veut dire que si vous maîtrisez ces cents mots là, si vous êtes capables de les prononcer
et aussi de les reconnaître dans une phrase,
vous aurez fait la moitié du chemin pour pouvoir parler dans n'importe quelle langue.
Parce qu'après, on le sait que quand on s'adresse à quelqu'un
le non-verbal aussi prend le relais et peut faire 50% de l'autre partie de la conversation
avec la situation dans laquelle vous êtes, avec l'expression du visage,
avec les gestes que vous pouvez faire. Par exemple ça, ça veut dire dormir.
Il y a pas besoin de connaître le mot pour se faire comprendre.
Je vais vous donner cette centaine de mots. C'est l'objet de ce Master Class.
Clairement, ça va être un Master Class chiant à regarder en fait, j'en ai bien consciance.
Mais je ne vois pas d'autres idées.
On va se le faire en rapide, puis après vous mettrez pause et vous pourrez le retenir.
On commence par les A :
Alors par les A il y a : le à
"j'ai", "tu as" du verbe "avoir", ces deux là sont importants
il y a "aime" dans le sens "j'aime quelque chose". Pas forcément dans le sens amoureux.
Ne me faîtes pas croire que dans la moitié  de vos conversations vous tombez amoureux.
"Alors" qui marche aussi avec "donc". "Ami", c'est important de savoir le dire.
"Après", "au revoir", "aussi", "autre", "avant" et "avec ( quelque chose )".
Ensuite pour les B, il faut savoir dire :
"beaucoup" dans ses deux sens, c'est-à-dire
"beaucoup" niveau numéraire, "Il y a beaucoup d'oiseaux dans le jardin".
Ou pour la force, pour l'intensité "j'aime beaucoup manger de la mayonnaise.
Et ça c'est vraie !
"Bon" et "bonne" quand quelque chose est bon.
Et forcément le "bonjour", la salutation de base.
Pour les C, il faut savoir dire "ce" ou "ci". "Ceci" et "cela" ça marche aussi..
"Chose" au sens abstrait du terme, "une chose" , "quelque chose".
"Comment" pour poser vos questions. Et enfin "content".
Pour les D : "dans", "à l'intérieur de/dans queque chose".
Le "de" pour la provenance " Je viens de Paris". Ou le "de" qu'on va utiliser dans "de nouveau", par exemple.
"Dehors", "dernier", "donc" qu'on a déjà vu avant. Et le verbe "dire"
pour au moins savoir dire "je dis" ou "tu dis".
Moi j'ai dis que cette vidéo ne serait pas la plus drôle.
Pour les E,  il faut savoir dire "elle", "en haut" (en hauteur/au dessus de quelque chose).
"Encore dans les 2 sens du terme.
C'est-à-dire, "encore un fois" par exemple (de nouveau). Ou dans le sens
"encore et toujours la même chose".
Et la conjonction de coordination "et" !
Mais, ou, et, donc, or, ni, car !
On m'a tellement fait cette blague avec "Olicard".
Pour les F, juste le verbe "faire" pour savoir dire "je fais", ça suffit.
Pour les G, il faut savoir dire "grand" pour pouvoir donner l'ampleur de la taille de quelque chose.
"Gens" qui permettra aussi de déterminer un groupe de personnes sans forcément l'identifier.
Pour les I, "ici (là précisément)"
Également "il(s)" dans le sens "il(s) ou elle(s)".
Et enfin, "il y a" pour "il y a quelque chose".
Pour les J, à part le "je" pour dire "moi je", ça c'est bon.
Pour les L, tous les classiques :
"le", "la", les", "leur(s)".
Pour les M : "mais", "mais j'avais pas dis ça".
"Même" dans le sens "le même" ou "la même chose".
"Le même navire, la même bière s'il vous paît".
On sent le mec qui a fait des croisières là.
"Merci" évidemment. "Moi" ça va avec le "je" mais c'est important de le connaître.
"Mon" et "ma" pour vos possessions.
On a fait la moitié du chemin !
Pour les N : "ne" pour "ne pas". "Non" également.
"Notre" pour notre possession commune, globale.
"Nous"et "nouveau"
Pour les mots qui commencent par la lettre O, c'est facile
il y a "oui" évidemment. Il y a "ou" et "où".
C'est-à-dire "ou bien quelque chose"
Et le "où" qui fait référence au lieu. Où est donc Or,ni,car. On y revient.
Pour les P, il y en a un peu plus. Il y a le "par-dessus" savoir dire "par-dessus quelque chose".
Le "parce que". Le verbe "penser" à la première personne du singulier.
"Petit", "pouvoir" à la première personne du singulier aussi, "je peux faire ça"
ça permettra de dire "Est-ce que je peux aller là".
"Place", un cite.
"Plupart", "la plupart du temps", "la plupart des choses".
Et enfin "plus", "pour", "pourquoi", "premier", "première chose" et "presque".
Pour les Q
OH ! On atteint la bonne vanne !
Pour les Q, il nous faut les 6 grands gagnants :
"Quand", "quelque", "que", "quel(le)(s)", "quelquefois"
Et enfin "qui".
Pour les S. On touche au but.
"S'il vous plaît" évidemment, il faut savoir le dire.
Le verbe "savoir" à la première personne du singulier, "je sais".
"Seulement", "si" dans le sens conditionnel. "Si vous ne venez pas, moi non plus je ne viens pas".
"Soit", "soit vous venez, soit je ne viens pas".
"Sous", "souvent" et le verbe être à la première personne du singulier, donc " je suis".
Et "sur" aussi. Pas dans le sens "j'en suis sûr" mais "sur quelque chose".
Il nous reste les T, les U  et les V, parce que les autres lettres il n'y a rien d'important à connaître.
"Tel(le)(s)", comme "telle est la question", "tel père, tel fils",
"tel un You tubeur qui essaye d'avancer sur la toile".
Ce qui me fais penser que c'est bien aussi de savoir dire "téléphone" dans n'importe quelle langue,
on sait pas si vous êtes perdu etc.. On peut se rajouter "téléphone".
C'est pas quelque chose de courant dans 50% des conversations
mais c'est important.
"Temps" pour l'heure.
"Ton", pas le poisson évidemment. "Ton" la possession : "ton téléphone", "ta caméra",
ou "votre téléphone, "votre caméra".
"Toujours", "tous", "très" dans le sens beaucoup.
"Trouver à la première personne du singulier, donc "je trouve".
Et enfin "tu" et "vous", mais dans certaines langues comme l'anglais, c'est la même chose.
Alors qu'en espagnol le "vous" c'est "usted(es)".
"Votre Grace".
Pour les U : "un" la quantité, "une chose" et "un" l'article.
"Utiliser" à la première personne du singulier, "j'utilise".
Et les 2 derniers : le verbe "aller" à la première personne du singulier
c'est pour ça que je l'ai mis dans les V, donc "je vais" et "je viens".
J'adorerai vous dire que c'est moi qui aie fait tout se travail de recherches,
mais non, ça fait des années qu'il y a eu des recherches qui ont été faites au préalable
par pleins de méthodes linguistiques
où l'on sait aperçu qu'en règle générale on utilisait 200 à 300 mots par jours au maximum
pour toutes nos conversations.
Tout ce qu'on a à dire !
Là je vous ai fais une liste avec cette centaine de mots précisément.
Vous avez 50% des mots qu'on utilise dans n'importe quelle conversation
de n'importe quelle langue dans le monde.
Sens la puissance linguistique monter en toi !
Ce que je vous recommande d'ailleurs, si vous voulez juste des notions comme ça dans d'autres langues,
c'est de traduire cette centaine de mots là, mais de manière phonétique.
Peu importe que vous sachiez l'écrire ou pas c'est pas la priorité
quand on veut apprendre à parler une langue pour se déplacer
ou pour communiquer réellement avec quelqu'un.
Le mieux est de demander à quelqu'un qui parle la langue
et vous recopiez vraiment à l'oreille ce que la personne dit.
Ça c'est imparable.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu. Surtout qu'elle vous servira !
C'est le but du Master Class du samedi, c'est toujours un peu plus compliqué
mais c'est beaucoup plus riche en informations.
Si vous vous abonnez à cette chaîne et que vous partagez la vidéo,
vous aurez fait 100% de ceux qui m'aide à faire connaître la chaîne
et les vidéos. Donc je compte sur vous.
J'espère qu'on se retrouvera ensemble sur scène pour les
Hallucinations Collectives
Ou mon spectacle : Fabien Olicard vous mentalise.
Mais surtout on se retrouve demain à 11H dans le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !